salut à tous alors on se retrouve pour
ce gros match entre de la bourdonnais et
mcdonnell alors à noter que me lapp
ordonné commence un peu à prendre de
l'avancé dans ce match et c'est un match
qui gagne au final à c'est assez
largement
mais je trouve cette partie quand même
intéressante à suivre pour la bien jouer
quoi et puis eu des rebondissements et
c'est intéressant ça ressemble un peu à
la partie d'avant au moins pour
l'ouverture et ben je vous brosse qu'on
s'y jette donc de 4 donc la vaunage 2 au
6 mai vous avez dit que ça pouvait
transposer dans la partie d'avant de la
sicilienne et on va voir
en fait c'est pareil c'est comme le 4 et
5 et 4 2 de la vidéo précédente
voilà ses trois fils qui a veillé à
trois qui avaient des âges six qualifiés
deux total donc la vallée bien préparé
des 4 et là il a joué le bouquet relief
alors qui sûrement pas le mieux je dois
dire puisque cercle et noir attaque
soutien aux cinq par trois fois mais les
blancs ou faire des quatre comme dans la
partie et bien le défendre
et de toute façon des quatre c'est un
coût que les blancs comptait jouer du
coup a du coup peut-être 47 pas hyper
bien placé c'était mieux de soi jouer
d'un v6 comme la bourdonnette faisaient
souvent dans ce match parce que la dame
finalement elle va elle va aider à faire
pression sur des quatre ont ramené dans
le cahier vert f5 où il est bien placé
et troisième point pour peut noter ces
dames investissent aussi fait pression
sur b2 donc plus difficile de développer
le phocéen
soit vous pouvez jouer bas c'est le coût
que j'avais joué mon staff prend fo
cette voie là et sur des 4e 5 pour faire
petit roi qu'ensuite et il s'est pas mal
pour les noirs se souvient que j'avais
en tête de jouer comme ça sur food et
renvoie la ffu faut deux pas fou detroit
mais c'était de jouer ces 4 donc j'aime
pas bien là enlever la tension au centre
mais là l'idée c'est de chasser le fou
de cette diagonale qui a doit revenir
vers eux deux et junk food et 7 et le
flou qui revient de ce côté on sait que
dans la française le foot cases blanches
ça peut être le souci
enfin il faut y penser savoir qu'en
faire et là sinon la rive à l'avenant g6
et il n'y a pas de raison qu'on n'y
arrive pas on n'est qu'à deux coups de
galets et ben il sera sur une belle
diagonale et il sera même dominant par
rapport à ce fond d'eux qui fait pas
grand chose donc moi je veux qu'on
serait peut-être de jeu comme ça côté
noir mais on va par ce qui se passe dans
la partie alors qu'elle y est certes il
ya eu des quatre dames b6 maintenant
hélas un coup je pense qu'on peut un peu
critiqué c'est qu'il y avait lieu 3 à ce
que ça apporte pas grand chose on a déjà
le jeu de quilles pour la troisième fois
qu'il ya trois cas et ses deux cavaliers
o3sis mieux d'essayer de se développer
en scène d'ouverture est là le push les
300 tout indiquée évidemment
voilà les blancs veulent se préparer le
petit rac le pire des cas très bien
défendre et aucun problème et voilà ça
c'était un coup d'ailleurs qui était
jouée par igor blacks c'est un grand
maître soviétique il n'y a pas très
longtemps et les noirs avaient joué
comme ça qui a et b 4 mai il avait pris
feu prend à noter donc si la dame prend
ben j'imagine qu'on peut simplement
jouer d'un des deux si on veut pour
preuve la finale il ya pas de problème à
un jeu comme ça il ya eu foule prend
sous des deux voies la foux 17es avec
les blancs il était rentré dans cette
finale il y avait gagné la partie va
alors après j'imagine ça se tient bien
pour le nord aussi mais c'est entre les
jets plus pour les blancs et égale quoi
voilà si vous voulez vous recherchez
cette partie dans la base nous on n'a
rien de notre affrontement donc ici et
les bains les jouets qui avait lieu 3 et
là j'ai bien aimé la réaction qui est de
la bourdonnais guesnain il a pris si on
prend effet trouvé quatre échecs et ça
tend un piège
d'ailleurs maldonne les pas tomber
dedans élevé relève de bien jouer
alors le piège c'est quoi ces fous des
deux qui serait un très rare alors non
pas parce que tu en d4 en l'air mais
attention à guesnain sous tombent dans
ce piège de prendre et si vous êtes par
une pièce jusqu'à y prend dame prend il
ya damas quatre échecs qui fait pas une
double attaque
et vous parlez vous donc non pas qu'ils
allaient prendre des quatre fautes mais
si on prend 1,5
puis on prend 2,5 et qui avait les prend
pourquoi parce que ce pion en fait et
chloé puisque le cavalier 300 francs
l'heure donc après par mon cahier prend
qu à l epr antilles on prend en fait dan
fante 3 et donc les noirs aurait déjà
gagné mission et pourrait gagner pion de
5,6 veulent dans la
dans la foulée voilà donc sur fouquet
quatre échecs pas de fous des deux mais
relève de bien joué de la part de
mcdonnell si on prend le 5 pions prend
le 5 et petit rohff donc là évidemment
on n'est pas trop ravi que les blancs de
ce vis-à-vis du roi et du cou
il jouera g3 pour ressembler à noter
éventuellement aussi que ceux qui
allient recettes
je n'étais pas très classe et l'aca qui
menace de me ranger 55 où on croit g3 ça
se comprend alors on peut penser que
laurent battles manger 3 mais pour
l'instant comme la position est ferme et
ça va ça tient le choc
ça me fait un peu penser à une partie
entre riches xgeva gagnant très connu
pour les joueurs française que je vous
conseille de regarder c'est une partie
en 76
ou avec les moeurs bassil fn parti
modèles avec des sacrifices et tout pour
s'en prendre aux rois et et d'ailleurs
s'il faut faire quand ils maintiendront
à exposer de jouer de la sorte alors là
il nous fait d'amener cette île se met
en face h quatre jours et que les blancs
donc pas plusieurs idées ça peut être
soit dramé droit ce cas chez soi
pourquoi pas d'aller à fond pour kg 5
en cas de prison prend du plomb mais
nadal en h5 et on va attaquer le long de
la colonne h mais là bien joué vraiment
bien joué de la part des noirs il va
sacrifier une pièce ouvrir le roi est
très thématique de ce genre position
cavaliers de ces prend en le 5 comprend
cavalli prend et lille joue jour h3 il
s'enlève à noter donc en cas de prise
dame prend là le roi va se trouver un
peu dans les courants d'air
on croise trois faits refouler 6 aux
menaces matt est déjà pas si simple pour
les blancs disons dame l'un des quatre
pendant la fiac et vanilla
et c'est 2 je sais pas mais il ya encore
échec le québec étant prise est encore
pire le roi va se faire mater donc ouais
ça s'arrêtait pas une super défense pour
les blancs on voit à quel point ça peut
être dangereux ce roi dans les courants
d'air et donc il fait froid je crois
qu'elle est prince 3 puis on prend des
quatre pas mal joué du tout vous
continuez nous voulons ouvrir les lignes
alors bien sûr d'être en faux pas faire
parce qu'il ya eu cinq échecs et prend
la dame donc
donc attention d'ailleurs oui je n'aime
pas obligé d'y aux cinq ans la dame mais
il ya même matt possible après tourcoing
3 c'est encore mieux si vous pouvez si
vous pouvez vous pouvez mater mais bon
ça ne gagne adam en général c'est quand
même bien de la partie
voilà comme ça c'était c'est un joli
match donc des quatre voies tg4 jouer
donc il couvre un peu tout et là le h5
chasse ce cavale est bon un autre ou qui
étaient quand même envisageable est
sûrement très bon c'était le 5
parce qu'on menace h5 maintenant je
ressens clouage on menace aussi aux
quatre puisque si ce pion disparaissent
quand même pas mal de protection autour
du roy keane qui se passe par une bonne
occasion et donc pas simple à gérer pour
les blancs mais h5 on peut comprendre
cavaliers f2 et dames 5 centralise la
dame est aussi veut passer la dame
devant le fou pour créer une batterie et
menacé des maths par la food & 3 bon pas
mal joué défend la case food et 6
et là il défend un peu tout fou c'est
sète hérault à jouer et finalement on se
rend compte que louis blanc eh ben ils
sont avérées agences et les pièces et
tous à sa part du coup h5 en fait
quand je vais comprendre donc après kg 4
gens venus d'autres up en arrière
méfiance qu'elle et qui revient ici
colmate bientôt il défend j'ai trop hâte
serra et comme vous avez eu cinq là ça
faisait vraiment plus mal aux blancs
quoi alors il ya eu 11 5
il est parti on en est là donc pour
l'instant il tient il tient la position
ils menacent dé changer le fou donc on
veut pas et enragé de fou 17 et là un
coup dont je suis pas fan mais qui est
pas mauvais en soi mais bon je trouve
peut-être un peu impulsif
c'est f4 parce que je sais pas avec va
direct au combat si c'est parce qu'il
est un boxeur qui veut que le corps à
corps et peut-être des moments c'est
bien le souffle et de penser à sa garde
et il a en gros je sais pas il n'y a
toujours pas développer toutes ces
pièces et un petit coup comme fou d2 en
garde l'option là en plus qui se
souvient de cavaliers on repassait de
diagonale de ses 6 je trouvais ça plus
logique et parme 5 ou 10 pouces et 6 où
les normes à échanger et faire d'alger 3
et ben pourquoi pas jouer autour h3
comme ça on défend les deux cases ici on
a toujours notre pièce de plus avec les
blancs à noter et puis bon on va bouger
adam ramener la torah en jeu et puis a
essayé de tes petits de souffler
reprendre le dessus et à mon avis
c'était une bonne manière de jouer votre
côté vous mais f cas de non pas une
faute mais juste
qena côté pratique c'est pas génial
alors inutile f5 joué et j'ai cinq bons
contre attaque la dame je fous détroit
il a fait pousser si c'est chaque
intermédiaire le roi s'en va et dames g4
et du coup c'est vrai que quand on voit
ça on se dit bon maintenant en finale
pièce de plus pour les blancs ça sent
bon et c'est vrai et mais je fais un peu
le contraire sur ce que pourrait être
quatre avant il a joué à cinq et parrain
il peut être sait mieux à un moment
d'activer les pièces quoi
kikou comme peut-être tour 2 ramène
cette orange longue colonne ici on peut
attaquer le pion sam hamad a l'air mieux
bon il a fallu cinq ans qui veut faire
sûrement ch si c'est vous la
contre-attaqué le roi noir et voilà et
là ok ni des pratiques assez
intéressante de la part de la bourgogne
ils jouent tout reprend un f4 crise
prises donc il nous fait une double
attaque
mais bon je rappelle que encore d'une
qualité qui avait lié aux 4 et là il
pourrait la retirer sa qualité mais le
problème je vois cette finale
l'exception de moins avec une pièce de
moins sert pour trois pions mais on voit
que ces documents là sont bloqués se
plonger 4 on ne va pas faire long feu et
on donne pas cher de la peau des noirs
dans ce genre de finale bon ce choix là
de jouer plutôt qu'une tour de main et
de l'activité pourquoi pas menace tous
rêvent de effet tour f1 et la torah 5 et
on voit le wave if i look avec un drap
s'il veut il veut nous faire du tord 5
pour portables et le cavalier ou quatre
en cas de prise bien sûr mon champion
prend on attaque ici et là avec les
blancs il ya qu un seul coup en fait
pour maintenir la montage donc juste
chercher si vous voulez
ce trouvable ce pas le plus simple se
trouve à aller je vous donne la réponse
c'était tourache 424 très bien joué
pourquoi on veut prendre ses pions
notamment sur un prime toro 5 comprend
et on défend donc la regarderai notre
tour plus est et tout ira bien
malheureusement pour le joueur irlandais
il a joué ce coup de tours h1 et après
tour 5 va devoir rendre une pièce est
dès lors maintenant les nord une qualité
pour trois pions et là davantage a
changé c est noir qui sont mieux tout
d'un coup pas donc partie à
rebondissements et les way et puis il
n'a pas laissé des souvenirs adversaires
il n'a pas échangé à toi honte à toi
réactive
il avance sans qu'ils ont passé et
il défend g7 tout va bien quoi quand on
est d'autant prendre cinq tours prend
1,2 il ya toujours ces trois pions pour
la qualité 3g 4 a été jouée pourquoi pas
bon il veut peut-être tenté un baroud
d'honneur à escoffier lab a créé des
réseaux de maths mais c'est un peu
voyant et ça va pas trop marcher
maintenant une pousse b5 donc ici pour
cette deuxième place est bien sûr on
peut pas apprendre de la tour parce
qu'on laisserait faire dame
il fallait à tours pour pour défendre
donc le pion béhary vie doublé tout
retour c'est un donc pareil les deux
tours bloqué sur la colonne des f5 pour
acheter est tombé ce pas faire l'ouvragé
6 il a appris les deux pour rendre la
qualité mais bon bain les deux filles
ont passé a et b vont faire la
différence et il ya eu abandon ici bon
parti assez intéressante qui toi une
fois de plus un avantage de la
bourdonnais donc vous disait qu'il va
gagner ce match assez largement donc
c'était une série de plusieurs matches
mais en fait ça va qu'elles seraient
d'expérience à un mcdonnell et tous les
autres matches seront beaucoup plus
discutés dans la foulée notamment jeu
suivant fait que mcdonald's gagnera et
et voilà donc on y reviendra dessus
quand je vous disais donc que ce soit
c'était des gros matches
c'est vrai quoi c'était pas même fils
auster était assez gros pour pour la
bourdonnais stone age il a gagné 15
victoires à six mais les parties étaient
relativement disputer quand même et y
avait de l'enjeu donc c'était c'était
sympa voilà bah écoute et on se retrouve
bientôt pour pour continuer avec eux a
découvert ce genre de la bourdonnette à
bientôt